they spend more money every single year
than it costs to build the towers
they're not very good wow wow I had this
horrible thought experiment I don't know
if Alan used this at all but the idea
was would you rather when something bad
does happen you pay out the families all
that money
and not spend it on the TSA
Oh that's oh
this is this is the trolley argument
just just frame differently I swear to
God
I had like a really [ __ ] scary
encounter when I was in uh it wasn't
scary we were in uh LAX yeah and uh you
know because I have my I have my bag
right which has every single wire and
Battery oh yeah so I always gets flagged
every single they hate my bags they stop
it every time they make me open it up
they make me [ __ ] and it's a mess so
it looks it doesn't look good it's not
neat pull out batteries batteries wires
wires camera yeah you know it's always a
thing and I'm I'm used to it happening
every single time yeah so I see my bag
go in you know because it goes down then
it can get like shuttle to the side yes
yes oh yeah when you see it when you see
it pop out of the side
I'm getting arrested and so I'm waiting
I'm waiting and then as I'm like seeing
my bag go down this other thing I'm like
[ __ ] 's sake I gotta tap on the shoulder
and I turn around and it's it's TSA this
is guy big dude that's like a smaller
guy and there's a bigger guy behind him
and he's like are you Connor and I'm
like yes yeah what's wrong he's like
and there's a really long pause and he's
like I love trash taste by the way
I was like I was like I lose I I was
like I smacked this off don't [ __ ]
scare me like that man
arrested
we're gonna kill you
it was so funny because
God damn it man I was almost because
this was on the flight to Miami right uh
yeah no Australia oh to Australia we
just got we'd flown from Miami to LA to
get a fight yeah that's right and I and
I had already like gone off because I
got all my [ __ ] and so from the distance
I just saw Connor getting surrounded by
TSA [ __ ] his pants I didn't have any
idea that that's terrifying oh I think I
think they knew you yeah he definitely
was playing it all for sure that kind of
sucks
it scared the [ __ ] out of me because I
turn around there's dudes just looking
at me and like menacingly I knew my name
oh they absolutely know how much power
they have yeah traveling in an airport
is already like a really bad experience
yeah oh man traveling to the US it's
like there is no country that is more
intimidating to get into than the US
yeah yeah holy I've never felt like they
interrogate you
uh because I was on an Esther and then I
apparently broke some rules that didn't
comply with yesterday that I didn't know
about and apparently that happens
smuggling drugs yeah apparently cocaine
is not allowed no but like I I basically
just broke a very kilos of Coke
yeah I was like oh [ __ ] six is too much
what's the difference yeah that's not
like I I basically long story short is
there's like a lot of very minor rules
about the esta the electronic visa thing
um that is not you know very concisely
written down yeah and I unfortunately
broke one of those rules and the guy was
like well it's all right because you
didn't know about it and this happens
all the [ __ ] time yeah so but but we
have to deport you oh my God and so I
was like oh okay uh well my girlfriend's
already gone through it's not a big deal
it happens all the time yeah does not
get followed up by we have to deport it
that's literally how they phrased it
they were like don't worry man it
happens all the time uh but you have a
choice you can either uh stay in a jail
overnight until we can get your flight
the next day or you can take this other
flight that takes you to Amsterdam
instead and then you have to get a
connecting flight back to Japan what
would you like to do and all I could
hear was like The Who Wants To Be A
Millionaire music just like
and I'm just like ah
yeah I was like it's like can I phone a
friendly so I uh yeah so I was just like
well I'm not [ __ ] staying in a jail
overnight so uh Amsterdam please every
time I go to the Border in America I
feel like a school kid like it was about
getting in trouble you're getting in
trouble yeah and like you go to them and
I feel like a school kid and the
teachers like scolding me it's like why
what are you doing here how long are you
here I'm like oh I'm sorry I I don't
know why but I always just feel like I
needed to to apologize even if I have
all the documentation even though I'm
not doing anything wrong I just I always
feel like sorry sometimes you just I
don't know I mean like a lot of the
times it's been chill but sometimes you
get that one dude who you can tell he
just likes it he's just having a [ __ ]
yeah yeah like you know asking questions
or you're like why would you ask that
question in that way like you're trying
[ __ ] this morning yeah yeah not even I
wish it was there that'd be fun yeah how
heavy was it
I don't know dumb [ __ ] it's because of
all the Border Police I've met in
America they even if they the most
chillest person in the world all of them
have like all of them are able to
project this Authority in their in their
voice that I've just seen like that that
is on another level compared to like
most other countries I've been to it's
it's like yeah and it's also like it's
also I feel like they have this switch
in Emotion the moment they deem you to
be okay because it's like every time you
walk up it's always like they've got
like some kind of Sourpuss like resting
[ __ ] face you know just like really
mean about it and then the moment they
stamp your thing it's just like oh
you're welcome have a good day have a
good day
thank you it's like oh thank God thank
you when I was a kid uh because my mom
wasn't a citizen she's from Sweden yeah
okay and so she had a green card we were
coming back from Mexico and I guess she
had left her green card at home and so
we had to basically sit there and argue
with immigration and they're like well
for 300 or whatever it was some stupid
fee that you know years ago would have
been more than what that is now we can
do it for you and figure it out
electronically or
you can go and get your green card and
so basically she stayed at LAX my dad
drove me my sister home and we must have
been like maybe 12. yeah so we're like
you know pretty young yeah he dropped
stuff at home and then drives like you
know in probably an hour and a half back
to LAX holy [ __ ] and this is like I
remember probably Landing it was dark
outside so maybe like 10 11 it was super
late so he probably got home at like
four in the morning after dealing with
it and they picked the whole like they
knew who she was they had everything
there but it was just like in order to
come through without the card you got to
pay like three foreign
just like uh but I've never had a bad
experience yeah with any any well I mean
airport security in any country uh
honestly not really that's good yeah
even either I I it's been chill I think
coming back from Canada is probably the
most aggressively I've gotten grilled
but I was driving oh they ask you what
you're doing there and whatnot but
otherwise I don't think anyone's super
I can't remember damn yeah I I think
I've been like interrogated a few times
um both of both those times
that's looking pretty bad I mean we're
both white we're like yeah
this is not looking this is not a great
look my brothers
that's privilege they're like how how
why did you say you were again yeah okay
you don't look very white yeah so your
name is Joseph okay you're you're good I
see your name is Gant Manny
I brought some stuff too they really
don't like too like one time we had a
suitcase filled entirely with magic the
Gathering cards
hated
what I don't know I guess it's just too
dense for the x-rays to penetrate and so
it just shows up as like this brick
that way wait okay hold on I gotta know
why are you bringing in a suitcase full
of Magic the Gathering I don't know
because we didn't use them at all I had
to drag it all the way back home and so
you put it through customs and they're
like hold up what is that what are these
white bricks and then of course like
it's literally filled with cards and
it's like how do you dig through a box
of cards that have been like
meticulously placed yeah for the guys
just you can just see them die on the
inside because you're sitting there
looking at them and they they know
they're not gonna be able to put it back
together yeah and so he just sort of
like picks up a couple of them and I
think he gets the vibe that like they
just cause it's just cards uh and so you
let us go but tools they hate tools too
we had to throw I had uh I think we were
in Texas and I had to buy a drill and
some drill bits and stuff
no you can't take a drill you can't take
anything the bits I understand he's like
throw a drill bits away but he wouldn't
let me take a drill and so I'm going to
let the battery out yeah so he's like
you have to check it and I'm like nope
throw it in the trash and he's like
he was like confused all right nope
throw it in the trash is there anything
else in my bag you want me to throw in
the trash like if there's anything in my
bag you'd like to throw in the trash
I think he started getting really
uncomfortable because I was just like
basically you know giving him the
authority to throw anything away that he
didn't like right he's like scream screw
you man yeah I just paid 80 bucks for
this drill I don't want to throw it away
oh [ __ ] you assessed the guy yeah I did
oh well I saw them in a way where I gave
him like too much Authority if there's
anything in my bag you want to throw
away do it right now I'm I'm too scared
to session yeah I feel like the moment I
do that I'm getting arrested I wasn't
arguing with him I wasn't saying no
don't take my drill it was just like
anything else you want to throw away no
but it's it's the passive aggressiveness
I could not do yeah yeah but I'm not
hindering him
you're an older man than me yeah I think
so